qu'est ce qui se passe aujourd'hui chez
apple
eh bien sans qu'on s'en rende compte
apple est en train d'opérer une de ces
révolutions premier savent le faire en
tout cas de continuer à évoluer sais pas
si vous avez suivi il ya très très peu
de temps apple a annoncé la sortie de
cette nouvelle machine ça c'est le
macbook pro 13 pouces qui tourne avec
leur nouvelle puce la plus propriétaire
qui s'appelle la puce m1 ou comme
diraient les américains aiment roanne
donc là on a la puce moines la nouvelle
et ils ont annoncé également un autre
produit hyper sexy c'est le mac mini
avec les puces m1 alors ce qu'on va
faire aujourd'hui on va regarder ces
deux produits on va essayer de
comprendre en quoi l'arrivée de cette
puce m1 est vraiment révolutionnaire
pour apple qu'est ce qu'elle va changer
et vous allez voir
elle va changer beaucoup de choses bien
plus qu'on ne pourrait l'imaginer
la stratégie n'est pas juste de se
séparer d intel pour avoir eux-mêmes et
fabriquer eux mêmes leurs puces la
stratégie va beaucoup plus loin au
niveau de l'expérience globale qu'on va
pouvoir avoir avec l'écosystème apple
que ce soit sur ipad sur iphone ou sur
son mac
mais avant de commencer si vous l'avez
pas déjà fait je vous invite à venir
vous abonner quand son petit bouton
rouge que vous avez là pour tout savoir
sur la tacc paraît effectivement des
nouveautés produits apple pas que apple
on parle également samsung huawei honor
shiomi et compagnie on parle surtout de
vous de votre vie numérique on parle là
des bons usages on parle des bonnes
pratiques à voir avec ces ordinateurs
avec son smartphone et sa tablette
et pour vous faciliter la vie quand
c'est très cool je n'habite ont calqué
son petit bouton rouge qui est juste là
si les rouges si vous n'êtes toujours
pas bonne et c'est pas bien ça des
coquins et vous acceptez la cloche comme
ça vous serez notifié dès qu une
prochaine vidéo arrivera et ça c'est
vraiment super
question du jour qu'est ce qui ressemble
plus à un mac cain autres bacs
vous avez là le nouveau macbook pro 13
pouces avec la puce est non et vous avez
là le macbook pro de l'année dernière
c'est le 16 pouces avec une puce intel
on a donc deux macbook pro qui se
ressemblent vraiment énormément autant
vous dire que chez apple la différence
ne se voit pas la différence est à
l'intérieur et c'est souvent ce qu'on a
pu voir et parfois reprocher apple au
niveau de ses iphone des grandes
encoches qui ne changent pas qu'on
retrouve d'une année sur l'autre avec
des produits qui pourtant ont des vraies
évolutions à l'intérieur mais une fois
de plus si apple c'est sous le capot que
ça se passe vu du dessus les macbook pro
13 pouces ressemble à s'y méprendre au
macbook pro 13 pouces est aussi le
macbook pro 15 pouces et aussi aux
macbook pro 13 pouces des générations
d'ados sur le côté c'est exactement la
même chose bon mise à part que sur le 16
pouces vous avez deux prises usb ses
opus à l'arrière rien ne change et l
avant non plus et c'est certainement pas
le clavier qui fera la différence
grand trackpad sur le macbook pro 13
pouces grand track pack au macbook pro
16 pouces mais à l'heure où apple vient
changer c'est pu se passer d'une telle
alors plus propriétaire ça paraît assez
normal qu'ils ne viennent pas changé
leur design pour rappeler qu'un macbook
pro s'étend même aux pros mais quand
même ou pro avec la puce m1 ira beaucoup
plus loin que macbook pro avec les puces
intel et le mac mini est toujours le mac
mini avec des connectiques usb et hdmi
usb une prise jack et de l'internet
oubliez l'alimentation ça c'est
important et sinon un design très épuré
comme apple sait les faire avec un joli
logo et une écriture mac mini en dessous
sais pas si vous avez gagné à lire ses
écrits si noir sur noir
la première chose qu'on va attendre avec
un changement de plus c'est d'avoir des
gains des gains de performance des gars
d'autonomie est ici apple nous annonce
des vrais gains significatifs sur le
macbook pro 13 pouces
les performances graphiques selon apple
sont multipliées par cinq au niveau du
processeur x 2,8 et au niveau du machine
learning x 8 et nous annonce une
autonomie qui est complètement dingue
une navigation sur internet jusqu'à 16h
et jusqu'à 20h en visionnage de vidéos
pur et dur autant vous dire qu'ici apple
annonce la couleur
nos machines avec notre processeur
marche beaucoup mieux que ces capable de
faire intel ont fait mieux qu intel on
va plus loin on intègre mieux et on va
beaucoup plus vite mais ça c'est la
partie émergée de l'iceberg
parce que le réel intérêt il est
beaucoup plus profond c'est d'unifier
toujours plus l'expérience utilisateur
grâce aux produits apple
jusqu'à présent ça se passait comme ça
vous aviez votre iphone votre ipad et
votre mac
je dessine pas très bien vous le voyez
une fois de plus si par exemple vous
utilisiez final cut pro pour le montage
qui est un logiciel apple
eh bien vous l'utilisiez sur votre mac
mais vous ne pouvez pas l'utiliser
ailleurs si par exemple vous utilisiez
photoshop si vous utilisez également
lightroom par exemple d'hadopi et bien
vous l'installer sur votre mac
mais vous ne l'utilisez pas ailleurs
enfin vous l'utilisez si ailleurs parce
que vous aviez vos applications
photoshop votre application lightroom
vous pouvez retrouver sur votre ipad ou
sur votre iphone mais il s'agissait ici
d'applications complètement différente
bon final cut pro
c'est un peu particulier qu'est ce qui
se passe aujourd'hui vous retrouvez
toujours votre iphone toujours votre
ipad est toujours votre macbook pro
alors ça peut être un macbook pro ça
peut être un hacker min ça peut être un
imac ça peut être ce que vous voulez la
vraie différence que vous allez avoir
aujourd'hui c'est que vous allez avoir
une seule application vous allez pouvoir
installer partout
vous allez pouvoir avoir un photoshop
qui sera exactement la même application
vous allez avoir un lightroom enfin dire
que trop c'est un peu différent final
cut pro il a besoin de ressources dont
il a besoin de beaucoup de performances
donc c'est encore un cas exceptionnel
peut-être que les applications comme
photoshop et lightroom n'allait pas
pouvoir les utiliser à fond de la même
manière sans votre ipad et sur votre
iphone mais ce qui est sûr et l'idée
globale est ce qu'il faut retenir
aujourd'hui c'est vous allez avoir une
application centrale que vous allez
pouvoir utiliser sur n'importe quelle
machine grâce à la nouvelle puce m1 et
c'est ça qu'ils dessinent aujourd'hui
vous avez des puces qui sont signés
apple de partout et vous avez des os qui
sont signés apple partout vous avez mac
os
vous avez un os et vous avez ipad os pas
tout de suite mais à terme lorsque les
développeurs pour vraiment adapter leurs
applications disponibles quel que soit
le device
vous allez avoir une expérience globale
qui va aller beaucoup plus loin que ce
que vous permettait de faire
l'architecturé intel
parce que là vous aviez des puces apple
vous aviez des puces apple et là vous
aviez une puce intel
donc c'est un vrai changement en
profondeur qui s'opère et tout ça bien
évidemment va venir en plus se
synchroniser grâce à icloud
voilà je vous prends volontairement en
exemple des applications que j'utilise
et qui vont peut-être être consommatrice
de ressources qu'on ne pourra pas
utiliser la même manière sur un ipad ou
sur un iphone comme on va l'utiliser sur
un mac qui ont beaucoup plus de
performances bien évidemment mais l'idée
est là par exemple vous téléchargez
votre application
netflix sur votre iphone sur votre ipad
et vous la voulez également sur votre
mac pas pour avoir une énième
application n'est parce que passer par
votre navigateur vous trouvé ça un peu
moins sympa etc avec une application
vous avez une meilleure interface vous
l'a positionné dans votre dock
c'est plus sympa c'est plus pratique
donc on à côté praticité demandera
surtout le côté efficacité productivité
que ce soit pour l' usage particulier
les âges professionnels imaginez un
logiciel où vous allez avoir la même
application disponible partout où tu
auras juste quelques fonctionnalités que
vous pourrez utiliser ou pas en fonction
de la performance de votre machine
c'est un peu ça l'idée c'est cette
unification est ce qui fait la force
d'apple et on en parle depuis très
longtemps c'est l'écosystème c'est la
façon dont tous les produits apple
fonctionne très bien ensemble
la façon dont ils sont complètement
optimisé d'un point de vue logiciel et
d'un point de vue matériel
avec cette nouvelle puce m apple va
encore plus loin n'a effectivement d'une
certaine manière faire du mal à intel
mais d'un autre côté ils vont gagner en
efficacité en compatibilité et vous
renforcez toujours plus la marque apple
et l'écosystème
alors il ya ceux qui n'aimeront pas être
enfermé dans un écosystème avec des
produits compatibles avec icloud au
milieu et y en a qui adorons qui
trouveront côté très pratique
moi personnellement j'aime beaucoup tout
ça très pratique
la compatibilité est très bonne les
différents objets communique très bien
entre eux et ça ouvre de nouvelles
perspectives
il faudra du temps que les développeurs
fassent des applications 100% compatible
quelles que soient les device mais pour
moi c'est la logique et c'est là dessus
qu'on va dit marc vous ce que vous en
pensez en bas en commentaire est ce que
vous êtes d'accord avec cette logique
que grâce à cette puce emv apple fait
bien plus qu apporter de nouvelles
performances
elle contribue à élargir et à renforcer
son écosystème produit avec icloud au
centre n'est pas ce que vous en pensez
en bas en commentaires ne se trouve
extrêmement rapidement pour continuer à
parler tech parce que oui parce que oui
il ya beaucoup de choses qui arrivent
notamment le test de ces deux machines
on va encore parler ipad on va parler
iphone
parce que oui il ya beaucoup à raconter
je vous parle d'apple je crois bien
évidemment de plein d'autres produits et
de plein d'autres marques sur ceux des
gros bisous et à très vite nom de
l'amour chaos
[Musique]